when my ticks come on i don't
really have a defense against it
and sometimes it just sort of comes out
in these
explosive spontaneous ways
i'm an actor with tourette's for a long
time i did worry about exposing that
because i thought it would affect
getting hired auditions whatever it
might be now i just put it on the table
it feels great to own it
my show is about having tourette's
syndrome and
finding my own way with it
tourette's syndrome is a neurological
disorder that you're born with the
stereotype about tourette's is that
people will curse uncontrollably which
people do i've never done that when i
tick i clear my throat i cough
sometimes i
make noises in my throat huh so
welcome to use that if you want
yeah riding the subway is rough i still
get nervous about it especially since i
have this throat clearing sniffing tick
i have tourette's syndrome that's
probably making that noise i can't help
him when i'm acting i don't tick
i remember somehow i'm like in this zone
and
i'm able to just focus it kind of just
like goes away and it says
okay take a break do what you love
and i'll be waiting for you when you
come back
you